Nationally
The budget in the Philippines goes to corruption
At twenty
Seventeen
To twenty
Eighteen
One point four trillion
Just went
In nothing
He suddenly disappeared
There are two
The impact of its corruption on our country
First first
Is the so-called
Economics
Already
Opportunities
Or already wasted
Opportunity
The impact
Corruption in our
Foreign
Direct
Is huge
Thirty years
We are the lowest in the entire asian region
Foreign
Direct investments
And it's not just because of our constitution
But also corruption
What those say
Investors
That's why they don't
Investing in the Philippines
Is due to rampant corruption
And the
Opportunity
Hopefully there will be more
Filipino work
o
The higher the salary is
The second reason is missing
Is more onting
Filipino investment
Or the so-called human
Capital
Instead the money goes to health care or to
Training at
Education
He only goes into the pockets of those
Individual
And this is the reason
So it becomes
A corruption cycle